- [Kelly] I feel like I
haven't seen you in forever.
- I know, I've missed you, how are you?
- COVID ruined all our lives.
So we mentioned that Rihanna's
doing the, the halftime show
at the Super Bowl, which is
my favorite part of the game.
- Me too.
(laughs happily)
- Yeah.
So do you watch, do you do the Super Bowl?
Do you?
- I do.
I watch and I make nachos.
I make very good nachos.
- Me too.
- Really?
- I, well I eat really good Nachos.
- I eat eat them too.
Do you have a secret cheese sauce?
- Nope.
I have a secret thing called a sister
who makes amazing food.
- Oh yes!
(Kelly laughs happily)
- Yes.
I'm a very good.
I'm a very good sous chef.
- Yes.
- I'm like, I don't
know how to do anything
but I know how to help.
- Yes.
- So I'm a helper, but I love,
I'm there for like the
mingling and the food.
- Yeah, it's really fun.
- Who in your family
are you looking forward
to seeing for like around Thanksgiving?
It's Football season.
- Oh, I love Thanksgiving.
I host it frequently.
I don't know if I'm doing that this year
but I have a little
niece who's two years old
who is just so much fun and
it's, everything's so new.
It's really fun to introduce her
- Magical.
- to little magical family traditions.
It's unbelievable.
I mean, she's just two in Halloween
so yeah, excited to party with her.
- Yeah.
Oh, that's such a magical age.
It's a fun time.
- She's sings a lot.
- Oh really?
- She wants everything the grown ups have,
unfortunately, we've taught
her the word margarita
(Kelly laughs happily)
and every drink, every
time anybody has something
she's like Margarita tatata.
(everyone laughs happily)
And so she's gonna be.
- That's how you sound
after drinking several.
Margarita tatata.
Not me.
I've just heard about it.
(everyone laughs happily)
So are you able to take
time off and just chill?
You always have like so many.
You always have a show going
on that I love by the way.
- That's nice.
Thank you.
- Constantly.
I know, but that's amazing.
Not many people have that
kind of shows you like
and nope, and also, nope.
And also like that are that steady
like doing constant like
shows that are doing well.
That's amazing.
- I've been really, really lucky.
- Yeah.
- Oh my gosh, thanks.
- Do you take a break though?
Do you ever take time off?
- This summer I had the first, you know,
'cause TV show summer is
usually like May and June,
which is not a great time to have summer
'cause that's not summer.
But this year I had like the whole,
I had July and August off
and I got very excited about that.
- Yeah.
- I had the summer off.
- You did?
- Yes.
- Why didn't we party?
- Well, I'll tell you why.
You could only find me in
the mountains in Montana.
- How great.
- I literally was on a four
wheeler the whole time.
I literally, I carved out the time.
I don't take time.
I don't feel like I love working
and I, you kind of seem
like you do as well.
So, it's kind of hard for me to stop.
So when I do, it was beautiful.
- [Lauren] Yes.
- But they shouldn't have shown me
'cause now I know what it's like.
- Exactly.
Well I got so excited.
I was staying by the beach
and there was a, the sort
of stand by the beach
that said kayak stand.
You can put your kayak
here by lottery only.
And so it's a combination
of excited about summertime
and overly competitive.
I entered the kayak lottery.
- [Kelly] Yes!
- And I got a space and thank you.
(everyone claps happily)
But then I had to buy a kayak
(everyone laughs genuinely)
because I had never been on
one and I didn't have one.
But I was so excited about
the kayak lottery that I-
- Wait, you've never been on a kayak?
- No but now I have.
- I love kayaking.
- I do too now that I won the lottery
(Kelly laughs happily)
- Now it's exciting.
- [Lauren] Now it's exciting.
- I would've gone kayaking
with you in the ocean.
- Maybe next summer.
- So is it true that your time off,
you also took a class on
a hostage negotiation?
What?
I love, we would vacation well together.
- We would for sure.
- I'd be like, sure.
- I belong to Masterclass.
You know the thing you can
subscribe to Masterclass
and it's all these experts on everything.
- Wait, what?
- And so I try to take something
that I wouldn't normally
use in daily life.
And one of them was hostage negotiating.
- I mean hopefully, it
doesn't come in handy.
- I hope not.
But I'm a handy person to
have if things go wrong
on our summer vacation.
But yeah, so I took hostage negotiating.
I took like tortilla making.
I took like, I just try to take random.
- I don't know this,
so I need to know this.
- It's really fun.
And the guy who teaches
hostage negotiating
is like exactly who you'd
cast to teach hostage.
He's like, "Listen, this
is what you gotta do
when you're trying to talk
him down off the hill."
I don't know why we're on a hill.
- Off the hill?
Not a building?
- No.
(everyone laughs happily)
- Don't jump off the hill.
- Hostage in the fields of Montana.
- That's amazing.
I would love to do that.
I never heard of the Masterclass thing.
That's cool.
- It's fun too 'cause it's just, you know,
in your all your free time.
- No but I do love, I
think that's so important
that you have something-
I sing all the time.
I love singing but like I'd
like to not sing sometimes
and do other things
like, so it's fun to like
- Yeah.
- like I've always wanna do like pottery
or like my sister would've
always wanted do stained glass
- Yes.
- like how to do that.
That'd be cool.
- There's a class for that.
You can do it.
- I need to do this.
Okay.
I'm gonna get the
information on what that is.
Okay, so congrats on the new book.
And so the new book is called,
"Have I Told You This Already?"
So why the title?
Do you tell a lot of
stories over and over again?
- Yes.
That's one of the main reasons.
I guess it's sort of a nod to the age I am
which is an age where
I've had such good friends
for so long that in some
cases I can't remember
if I've told them the story already,
if they were there with
me when it happened.
If they know the most recent version like
it's sort of just about
having known somebody a really long time
and just, it came out of pandemic times
of thinking of kind of the stories
that have meant a lot to me in my life.
Many of them told to me by my dad
and sort of what's my version of that?
Like what are my sort of
greatest hits I guess.
- Yeah.
Did you grow up wanting to be a writer?
Were you always into it?
- I grew up a really serious reader
and that was kind of a
gift given to me by my dad,
who was a great storyteller of his stories
from his own life,
but also would read to me every night
so I could read when I was really little.
I actually skipped kindergarten
because the teacher left
the room is the seventies
and she came back.
- Smoke break.
(both laughs happily)
- And I was reading a book to the class
and she wondered if I'd memorized it
or if I actually could read.
So reading was really important
and storytelling I think is
how I ever got interested
in being an actor.
It's just like, I would imagine
that I was the panda bear
or whatever.
I don't know again what story this is,
but so writing kind of feels
like a natural extension
of that I think
- Yeah.
- it's like a way for me to tell a story
on my own you know,
without needing a production necessarily.
- Yeah and our imagination,
I say it all the time,
there's no budget with your imagination.
So, it's like really cool.
It's not like a movie or TV thing.
You can really create whatever you want.
That's why I love books.
- I love fiction and this is non-fiction,
but in this one in particular,
kind of the titles come to me
and then I write the story around it.
- Yeah.
- So it's been interesting
as I have more experience
and as I write more, it's almost like
I don't know if you have
this music, but it's more-
- I was like, I do titles
like that by the way.
With songs.
- Really?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
I write, I literally
have one of my next album
called Skip This Part.
And I was like, I just
wanna skip this part
of this whole devastating situation.
And so I wrote the whole song
around, I do that as well.
- So, I think it's like
that's how your brain
tells a story, right?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And so that's some of these
there's one called Boobs of
the Nineties for example.
(Kelly laughs happily)
- That just kind of came to me
and I was like, "What is this about?"
And it's kind of about,
it's about how things have
changed since the '90s
but my boobs were stuck in the same place.
I don't know, you read it,
you have to buy the book,
(Kelly laughs happily)
but in the way that I think probably,
you know the song you think of the idea
and then the rest of
the song comes to you.
That's sort of what this is.
- [Kelly] Yeah because there's the theme.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Boobs and then '90s.
- Old boobs.
- [Kelly] So much.
(everyone laughs happily)
I wanna mention this quote from the book.
It's "Maybe turning fears
about aging and mortality
into contemplation and comedy
is just one of those things
women are better at."
So, what does that mean to you?
It's a great statement.
- Thank you.
I guess it was-
There's an essay where I'm talking about
Nora Ephron specifically,
who's a writer I really admire
who wrote, who was an essayist
as to wrote a number of essays
on aging and being, you know,
noticing her friends all
wearing like turtlenecks,
trying to hide that
they were getting older.
And I just as a matter of research
was looking into men
who've written about aging.
And I looked up men, women's necks, aging.
- Yeah.
- The only thing that came up was
why do are men so
attracted to women's necks?
And I was like, what?
Like there's no writing, there's no male.
There is less men writing about aging
in any kind of comedic
way or contemplative way.
And I thought, "Gosh, this
is maybe just something
that women are really
trying to process and-"
- [Kelly] And I think
it, people talk about it
more with women.
- Sure.
- [Kelly] They're always
like, "Oh, he is a fine wine
- Yes.
- [Kelly] and got better as he aged?"
- Nobody says that about women.
She looks so great at 60.
You know, I'm saying nobody's
really generally saying
that when they do, I find age beautiful
because I have had friends
that didn't make it past 30.
- Yeah.
- Like, you know what I'm saying?
We're lucky.
- Yeah.
- I find these wrinkles.
I earned these, I got these.
- I agree.
Yeah.
- And it's a beautiful thing
because not everybody's given that chance
to have that lifetime.
(everyone claps genuinely)
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] And age is awesome.
- Age is awesome.
- It's interesting though
that women are and maybe
we're more comfortable
talking about it because
people project it on us
all the time that-
- I think it's like one of
those things women are good at
which is turning a potential
negative into something
that we can learn from or
something to feel that's funny.
We can share, we can feel positive about,
we can laugh with our friends.
I just think it's kind of
a uniquely female thing
at least in my limited Google
research of looking up women.
- I know.
I was thinking like, I
always think if I die,
what are they gonna find in my history?
- Yeah.
- And I love that
like boobs of the nineties,
like women's necks.
(Kelly laughs genuinely)
It's like all your your
Google history is awesome.
- Yeah.
- So what, you've written a few books now,
we were saying this is your fourth.
So have you ever considered,
I know you like science fiction.
Have you ever considered doing that?
- I don't know.
I write very reality-based
but I think it would be cool
to take one of my characters into space
and see what would happen?
- I think you would be great at it.
You're, I mean you're a
great writer in general.
- I mean, Hollywood is
kind of outer space.
- It is outer space.
- What do you think?
- I would say it's the
capital from "Hunger Games."
- Yes.
- Where I'm from.
Everyone looks real different here.
- Yeah.
(everyone laughs happily)
- So, well, since we both like
space and Thanksgiving food.
Wanna play a game that we have a game
called Planet or Pastry?
- Okay, great.
- [Kelly] Both are cool.
- I know you're excited about it.
I can feel it.
We need a, you don't have a choice.
You're playing Lauren.
- Okay, great.